now tonight the harmful effects of
biden's open borders agenda are on full
display once again as the crisis
continues to worsen now yesterday the
dea announced law enforcement they
seized nearly 1 million fentanyl-laced
pills
which officials believe are linked to a
cartel drug trafficking operation
meanwhile texas senator ted cruz he was
at the border overnight last night where
he highlighted the quote human misery
all caused by joe biden's open borders
senator cruz joins us now with reaction
at what he saw senator i've been down
there 15 times i've been on horseback
all-terrain vehicle
boats helicopters walking with border
patrol been there when
when gang members were arrested been to
the drug warehouses
massive floor to ceiling filled with
drugs what did you see
well i've been here the last two days i
brought a group of seven senators down
to the rio grande valley and and i gotta
tell you it's the worst i've ever seen
it it continues to get worse and worse
and worse it is utter chaos we went out
last night on midnight patrol with the
border patrol within minutes we began
encountering illegal aliens just within
minutes we encountered a group of three
teenagers two boys and a girl from from
honduras and mexico they turned
themselves in to the agents we were with
a few minutes after that we saw a group
of about a dozen mostly
women and children it included
two seven-year-old girls each of whom
was an unaccompanied minor in other
words they weren't sisters they had no
parent they had no adult with them
two seven-year-old girls who were
absolutely beautiful and precious with
long pigtails you and i are both fathers
sean imagine handing a seven-year-old
child over to vicious human traffickers
this is happening over and over and over
again and these kids are being horribly
treated that same spot we were we saw a
patch of grass just by the edge of the
river where just days earlier two little
girls aged five and six
had been violently raped by the drug
cartels
this human tragedy is getting worse and
worse and worse and joe biden and kamala
harris of the democrats they don't give
a damn about it they're not willing to
do anything to fix it they don't give a
damn about it because if they did they
would have stopped it now you were the
first on this program
uh we couldn't get our cameras when they
had all these kids in the cages and if
it wasn't for people like you giving us
the video that you took when you
demanded to go inside and see it we
wouldn't have been able to show the
public what happened
now because they know that that it's it
is a process release
policy it is drawing all of these people
here
and then the drugs on top of it because
all the resources are now focused on the
people so all these drugs are getting
into the country and it's killing our
kids and you see a humanitarian disaster
you're describing two seven-year-old
girls it breaks your heart
that's exactly right you know on on the
banks of the rio grande just in the
grass you you found
wristbands which which i found on the
ground here a couple of white ones
uh here's a pink one uh here's a green
one
and they're all color coded this is a
yellow one
all of these are color coded for how
many thousands of dollars the people the
people wearing them oh the cartels
this yellow one
is tiny this was obviously worn by a
child it's not broken the child's hand
was small enough to slip it off without
it this is a little child a little girl
a little boy who is now in america and
finds herself or himself owing drug
cartels thousands of dollars and what
happens
next
is that these kids the biden
administration ships them to every city
in america even if you don't live on the
southern border you're in a border town
because there are kids in your town
there are 14 15 16 year old boys who owe
the drug cartels thousands of dollars
they're working for the drug cartels
committing crimes in your town and as
bad as that is the girls have it worse
because the girls find them over and
over again trapped in sex slavery this
is immoral it is horrific
and and sean there's a reason that joe
biden
hasn't been to the border once as
president there's a reason kamala harris
has not been to the rio grande valley
once as vice president even though she's
supposedly borders are because you can't
look at this horror and defend it joe
biden found the time to go to saudi
arabia but not to the southern border to
the worst illegal immigration in 62
years and i got to say sean
the body bags are piling up we saw just
a few weeks ago over 50 illegal
immigrants in a tractor trailer outside
of san antonio die of heat exposure
including kids as young as 13.
last year we had a hundred thousand
people die of drug overdoses with this
fentanyl exposure explosion
and the joe biden body bags keep getting
worse and worse and worse
and sean
the only good thing of all of this
horror
is it's opening people's eyes i think
november is going to be a red tidal wave
i think south texas is going to turn red
and if and when republicans retake
congress i believe one of the very first
priorities
is that we should impeach department of
homeland security secretary alejandro
mayorkas i think the house will do that
and the senate needs to conduct a trial
we need to put on a trial and put on the
evidence of the people that are
suffering and dying as a result of joe
biden's dereliction of duty
senator i mean it is a heart-wrenching
report and you know we've now gotten to
the point where joe biden's policies are
aiding and abetting law breaking we'd be
we would be charged with human
trafficking if we did what they're doing
and now your governor governor abbott
you know too much to his credit who's
tried to do everything
within the legal
system is now forced to push people back
over the border uh technically he's
that's not his job by law
but he has no choice at this point
and in less than until we finish that
job it's going to continue to get worse
and that humanitarian disaster that you
articulated uh will get worse as well
senator thank you for sharing that i
hope people hear you loud and clear hey
sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else